Oprah Winfrey runs into a cute kid who  has no idea who she is everybody can  take a deep breath now  [Music]  your dad works here right okay  $10 what's my name as one of the most  successful women in the world even Oprah  has those moments where people don't  know her name during a take your kid to  work day the legendary talk-show host  gets playful with a staffer son visiting  the own headquarters and even her hints  didn't help him hi  come on four starts with an O three two  one you lost starts with an O how many  old names are there come on  Oh feel ya oh my my Oprah Oprah  captioned the funny clip quote hard to  impress kid these days and now people  who didn't even know who she was are  gonna know who she is  [Music]  you